madame monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
que nous allons développer dans ce
journal
la veuve de l'ancien préfet de corse
publie une lettre ouverte demandant au
gouvernement de se positionner
clairement sur la question de l'amnistié
l'indignation de madame erignac qui sort
de son silence
les déclarations de lionel jospin sur
lesbo la libanaise déclenché une petite
tempête diplomatique et politique le
premier ministre parle d'une autre voie
que celle du chef de l'état aujourd'hui
il tente de dédramatiser le fils du
pétrolier erika et est considérée comme
potentiellement cancérogènes la fiche de
sécurité n'a pourtant pas été diffusée
auprès des bénévoles
un silence embarrassant les suites de la
visite de jean paul ii au proche-orient
demain le saint père se rendra au
buisson ardent et sur le mont sainte
catherine
là même où selon la bible dieu est
apparu à moïse présentation de ce
monastère vous pour but d'ouvrir ce
journal avec ce document à charge qui
pourrait bien constituer l'un des
premiers éléments filmés démontrant les
atrocités des troupes russes en
tchétchénie les répercussions de ce
reportage sont difficiles à mesurer mais
à coup sûr elle touche également
l'opinion publique en russie puisque ces
images sont diffusées sur toutes les
chaînes de télévision du pays alors que
les autorités du kremlin tente encore de
faire croire à une manipulation
les images sont difficiles gilles rabin
ces soldats russes qui marchent à visage
découvert devant la caméra aurait décidé
de laisser un journaliste allemand
filmer ce que l'état-major interdit de
laisser voir une opération de nettoyage
la fouille maison par maison d'un
village goiti près de grozny et le
contrôle de tous les habitants parce
qu'il serait contre les ordres coordonne
les soldes à l'aise tout voir chacun
valide doit se dévêtir pour prouver
qu'il ne porte pas les bleus
caractéristiques que laissent les
physiques
même sans marque tout hommes en âge de
porter une arme et embarquer vers un
point de contrôle où un camp pour la
première fois les sodas laisse aussi
filmer les fosses communes où sont jetés
les cadavres des tchétchène tué
combattants aux civils
on ne sait pas des corps sont attachés
avec du fil de fer certains ont
l'oreille coupée
toutes les chaînes de télévision russes
ont ouvert aujourd'hui dans journaux
avec ces images npv la principale
télévision privée de russie a interviewé
par téléphone le journaliste allemand
qui dit avoir réalisé ce document dans
ce document il n'ya rien d'artificiel
il n'a rien de refaire c'est comme
c'était certaines télévisions montrent
ces images pour informer d'autres pour
dénoncer une opération de désinformation
en tout cas pour la première fois tous
les russes de russie peut voir la
violence d'une guerre qu'ils apposent
dans leur majorité dans les journaux du
soir le porte-parole du kremlin pour la
tchétchénie accuse deux journées
seulement d'avoir menti ce n'est pas lui
qui attendait ces images mais le journal
izvestia
ce journaliste allemand et sa compagnie
de télé ne travailleront plus jamais en
tchétchénie dans le caucase
pour le kremlin ces d'une falsification
lancé à dessein le jour de l'arrivée à
moscou du représentant du conseil de
l'europe
alvaro gil robles qui doit se rendre en
tchétchénie pour enquêter sur les camps
de filtration et les atteintes aux
droits de l'homme et puis bill clinton
appelle moscou ce soir à autoriser une
enquête sur ces êtres cité en france
dominique erignac la veuve du préfet
assassiné sort de sa réserve et
interpellent l'état en publiant une
lettre ouverte dans laquelle les
demandes au gouvernement de se prononcer
clairement et sans ambiguïté sur la
question de l'amnistié des criminels
corse cette lettre reflète l'indignation
et la douleur de madame erignac qui
appelle à une juste cent ans pour ceux
qui en a abattu son mari agnès vahramian
valérie for you
c'était qu'il y a quelques semaines lors
d'une cérémonie du souvenir à son mari
dominique erignac venait de donner une
de ses rares interviews à la presse et
critiques à l'encontre de matignon
vous êtes sévère aussi peut-être vous
posez des tas de questions des questions
qu'elle pose aujourd'hui au gouvernement
est il si difficile écrit la veuve du
préfet assassiné
est il si difficile de dire qu'il n'est
pas question d'amnistié les assassins
pousser les politiques à sortir de
l'ambiguïté voilà le but de madame
erignac
insatisfaite des réponses de lionel
jospin tentera cette question de
l'amnistié que vous avez est votée elle
met en rien une question que je me pose
mais cette amnistie les nationalistes
ont l'air d'y tenir
l'opposition et plusieurs ministres dont
jean pierre chevènement se sont déclarés
contre même si la question n'a pas été
abordée lors des réunions des élus
corses à matignon jean guy talamoni
leader de corsica nazione admet que ses
propos à nice ti pour tous les militants
peuvent choquer il veut sont expliqués
et a écrit à dominique erignac
cette démarche situés exclusivement sur
le plan humain et le voulions créer les
conditions d'un contact direct
madame erignac et nous afin qu'elles
puissent se connaître sans passer par
des filtres déformant le fond de notre
pensée et notre état d'esprit nous
attendons sa réponse que les prisonniers
rentrer chez eux comme après un conflit
c'est la position des simples mouvements
clandestins qui ont décrété une trêve en
décembre dernier et pour qui l'absence
d' amnistie est inconcevable
après les deux attentats qui en novembre
dernier en plein jour en touche et
l'urssaf et la direction départementale
d'ajaccio suscitant alors une très vive
émotion
une dizaine de personnes sont en garde à
vue depuis cet après midi certaines
pourraient appartenir au mouvement
corsica viva wine de ces mouvances le
point avec yasmina farber et diane
richard l'enquète commence par hasard un
règlement de comptes sans envergure pour
un différend familial
le plasticage d'un appartement d'ajaccio
en bord de mer la sûreté urbaine
interpellent trois hommes mail enquête
prend une tournure très différente quand
l'un de crack
il accuse ses deux complices de faire
partie du commando responsable des
attentats du 25 novembre dernier en
plein jour les bâtiments de l'urssaf et
de la dde son souffle et sept personnes
blessées
le mouvement clandestine ou revendiquent
ces actes terroristes la corse est sous
le choc
les suspects seraient des militants ou
des proches du mouvement corsica viva
les responsables nationalistes considère
ces interpellations
comme un fait d'armes politique cette
vague d'arrestations dans les milieux
nationalistes
est le fruit d'une politique délibérée
de ce que nous appelons nous les
antilles évolutionniste à commencer par
monsieur chevènement et ses amis est ici
en corse la gauche et la droite
conservatrice mais srpj d'ajaccio et la
division nationale antiterroriste
continuent leurs investigations six
hommes et cinq femmes restent en garde à
vue à l'hôtel de police
d'ici à dimanche matin certains
pourraient être déférés à paris au
parquet antiterroriste nouveaux
développements concernant la cargaison
du pétrolier erika ou les silence
coupable des autorités qui dès le
naufrage savait que le tanker
transportait un fuel lourd classé parmi
les produits cancérogènes
reste que la fiche de sécurité établi
par total fina a été oubliée ou
dissimulé lorsqu'il s'est agi de faire
appel aux bénévoles
s'il mariné et l'évier sio ces
volontaires sont bien équipés mais le
fioul s'infiltre partout notamment dans
lego important quand vous vous habillez
vous mettez votre combinaison vous
mettez les gants et puis où les scotcher
carrément comme ça vous ai pas donné au
poignet comme vous avez tous les ennuis
éruptions cutanées démangeaisons les
volontaires savait qu'il pouvait
encourir ce genre de désagrément mais ce
que l'administration ne leur a pas dit
c'est que ce fioul lourd est classé
parmi les produits cancérogènes total
final affrêteur de l'erika on avait
pourtant averti les autorités dans une
note d le naufrage les laboratoires
privés ont tiré la sonnette d'alarmé
enfin le 21 décembre la cellule anti
poison basée à rennes remet un document
à la direction de l'action sanitaire et
sociale
il ya bien un risque cancérogène mais le
rapport du docteur bert ne sera pas
rendu public
moi j'ai donné une note qui permet de
comprendre le raisonnement qui aboutit
aux recommandations de la dass elle a
élaboré les recommandations pour qu'elle
soit opérationnelle
sinon il aurait été plus simple si on
vous laisse également d'afficher ma note
mais elle n'était pas compréhensible par
tout le monde et elle risque est
peut-être de déclenché de violentes
réactions puisqu'il faudra attendre le
21 février pour que le ministère de
l'environnement admettent le risque de
cancer que le docteur bert lui-même juge
très réduit
dans le cadre du scénario qu'on a retenu
des bénévoles protégés qui ont des
contacts accidentels épisodique suivie
d'un nettoyage de la peau il n'y a pas
d'excès de risque pour fabriquer un
cancer à condition d'avoir été bien
équipé ce qui ne fut pas forcément le
cas pour les tous premiers volontaires
des études sanitaires sont en cours sur
des milliers d'entre eux pour l'heure
sur le risque de cancer les pouvoirs
publics n'ont pas souhaité faire plus de
commentaires aujourd'hui devant la cour
d'assises de l'aveyron les premiers
témoignages des anciens élèves de l'abbé
morel une phase cruciale dans ce procès
qui a débuté en milieu de semaine dans
une ambiance délétère dominique
verdeilhan blaise craignais daniel
pesait attendu près de 40 ans avant de
parler publiquement
sa voix est tremblante blanche teintée
d'émotion mais il dit qu'il n'a rien à
cacher en 58 daniel pesait des demi
pensionnaires en 6e au collège saint
pierre
j'avais l'image d'un symptôme dit il en
parlant de l'abbé morel mais sans
regarder une seule fois l'accusé le
témoin évoque une enfance douloureuse
baisers caresses attouchements il me
disait je t'aime
les mots sont enfin lâchés jean-lucien
morel avait 30 ans daniel posait en
avait 8
je regrette de ne pas avoir parlé plus
tôt dit-il mais je me disais que la baie
était rentré dans le branchement
je suis là pour faire parce que moi j'ai
je vais être souffert mais pas comme un
corner jeunes
je crois que je suis sort a ému mais
mais sera mécontent d'avoir dit ce que
j'avais à dire
pierre gérard avait 14 en 1981 il était
en 5e il demandera à quitter le collège
au bout de deux trimestres
l'abbé morel s'était dit il le directeur
un prêtre un enseignant il représente l
autorité je ne savais pas comment mettre
un terme à cette relation il devait mai
mais sincèrement mais ce ne sont pas des
choses à faire aux enfants conclut le
témoin et moments très forts à
l'audience l'ancien élève regarde son
maître et le supplie je veux simplement
dit de voir son coeur pour faire éclater
la vérité rien dans la salle l'ambiance
est trop lourde les témoignages des
anciens élèves ravive les souvenirs des
jeunes plaignants chacun leur tour au
bord du malaise
les trois enfants claude y ans et en
direct de retester munich verdeilhan au
terme de cette journée il semble que la
thèse du complot largement développée
par la défense ne tient plus oui mais
jusqu'à présent les faits qui ont été
évoqués par les témoins sont prescrits
trop anciens le juge l'avait morel
pardon et bien n'est pas jugé pour les
faits évoqués cet après midi mais vous
l'avez dit on est bien loin de du
complot des rumeurs des ragots de cette
atmosphère de corbeaux qui plane ici à
rodez depuis deux jours alors sans
parler de rebondissements on peut parler
de confession l'abbé mort elle nie
toujours farouchement les viols en
revanche il est nettement plus trouble
sur les gestes déplacés
j'ai peut-être perdu la mémoire dit il
je ne crois pas et puis ensuite il
reconnaît qu'il avait un penchant pour
un des témoins il concède même un amour
platonique alors un procès qui avance un
procès où tout peut arriver et du prêtre
à qui l'on pouvait donner le bon dieu
sans confession selon l'expression d'un
témoin eh bien on passe ce soir aux
amitiés particulières d'un curé de
campagne
merci dominique verdeilhan la
condamnation par le tribunal
correctionnel de paris de serge humpich
à dix mois de prison avec sursis
cette peine est inférieure aux
réquisitions du parquet à l'encontre de
cet informaticien pirates de cartes
bancaires
plus exactement poursuivi pour avoir
réussi à percer le code d'accès des
cartes à puce serge humpich compte faire
appel ne comprenant pas ce jugement
puisqu'il n'a commis aucune infraction
selon lui il s'est contenté de démontrer
que le système n'était pas tout à fait
fiable au chapitre politique la
démission annoncée de roland dumas c'est
en début de semaine que le président du
conseil constitutionnel en congé
pourrait faire part publiquement d'une
décision désormais inévitable l'amenant
à quitter de lui-même ses fonctions
après son renvoi en correctionnelle en
marge de l'affairé à redouter selon ses
avocats roland dumas réfléchi il
décidera lundi ou mardi s'il reste le
président du conseil constitutionnel
depuis son renvoi en correctionnelle les
pressions se multiplient et des voix
s'élèvent pour demander aux huit autres
sages du conseil de sortir de leur
réserve je pense qu'il faut éviter toute
polémique et que les seules la seule
façon de l'éviter c'est précisément que
l'instance qui est habilité d'autant
plus que finalement elle est concernée
et bien disent le droit
certes une fois encore deux arguments
oppose la classe politique
la présomption d'innocence est l'image
du conseil constitutionnel chargé de
faire respecter le droit
mais avant que roland dumas ne s'assoit
au banc des prévenus yves guéna le
président par intérim du conseil
constitutionnel a réuni ses sept
conseillers pour trancher
tous lui aurait fait savoir que roland
dumas doit se prononcer
de préférence pour une démission
volontaire au nom des sages
yves guéna s'est donc entretenu avec
roland dumas
les deux hommes ont ils régler les
modalités de départ de l'ancien ministre
mystère roland dumas avait été nommé par
françois mitterrand s'il démissionne
c'est donc jacques chirac qui choisira
un nouveau conseiller et un nouveau
président à la tête du conseil
venons en maintenant à ce qui fait
figure de petite bombe diplomatique
après les déclarations des neiges spa
hier à jérusalem qui a donné sa propre
vision les actions du hezbollah au
proche orient les répercussions ne sont
pas négligeables et en france l' affaire
prend une tournure politique puisque le
premier ministre s'exprime d'une voix
différente de celle tenue par le
président de la république en étant de
surcroît sur les terres du chef de
l'état qui traditionnellement gère la
politique étrangère lors d'abord la
suite du voyage du premier ministre qui
rencontrait yasser arafat aujourd'hui
sur place jacques rivard une petite
phrase qui est devenu l'événement du
jour au proche orient
tollé dans la population et la presse
arabe applaudissements dans les journaux
israéliens
lionel jospin ne se doutait peut-être
pas d'une telle réaction hier lorsqu'il
a évoqué le face à face entre le
hezbollah et l'armée israélienne au
sud-liban épargner les populations
civiles est une contrainte que s'efforce
de respecter israël qui est attaqué par
des actes terroristes et nous condamnons
ces attaques
le téléphone a fonctionné les revues de
presse sont arrivés ce matin lionel
jospin discute avec les ministres qui
l'accompagnent et ils constatent
l'ampleur de la faire et notamment la
réaction très hostile du liban d'autant
que sa tournée ici est loin d'être
terminée après israël les territoires
palestiniens après août barack yasser
arafat
certes le ton et les gestes sont
chaleureux les deux hommes se
connaissent depuis 20 ans certes la
france reste ici la bienvenue l'aide
économique qu'elle apporte aux
palestiniens n'y est pas pour rien mais
la petite phrase de lionel jospin
continue de faire débat
il faut dire que ça ne fait pas plaisir
aux palestiniens ni aux arabes ont
détruit comme cela mais bon peut-être
c'est la diplomatique de monsieur j'ose
pas une mise au point va intervenir en
fin d'après-midi l'ironie du sort c'est
dans la vieille ville de jérusalem
là même où jacques chirac avait il y a
trois ans violemment protesté contre la
présence de l'armée israélienne que
lionel jospin reparle du hezbollah et
cette fois il n'est plus question de
terrorisme
au moment où les gociations nous est
difficilement entre israël et la syrie
je pense que ce n'est pas le bon moment
pour les actes de guerre
mais ce soir nouveau coup de théâtre
jacques chirac demande au premier
ministre de prendre contact avec lui une
chose est sûre il ya désormais une ligne
j'ose pas en politique étrangère
une ligne qui le cas échéant
s'affranchit des positions
traditionnelles de la france une ligne
surtout qui se démarque de celle de
jacques chirac
voilà sur un terrain inédit une nouvelle
source de tension dans la cohabitation
jacques chirac était ce matin en mayenne
le chef de l'état n'a pas commenté les
propos du premier ministre mais comme on
vient de vous le dire en toute fin de
soirée un communiqué annoncé que le
président de la république avait demandé
que les neiges sera prennent contact
avec lui dès son retour en france
dans l'opposition les réactions se sont
multipliées tout au long de la journée
hervé de charette l'ancien ministre des
affaires étrangères aujourd'hui député
udf demande à lionel josse pas de
retirer ses propos irréfléchis
quant à philippe séguin il s'insurge
contre l'incursion solitaire du premier
ministre et demandent une mise au point
ferme du chef de l'état je vous
proposais l'écouté li m'étonnerait fort
que tout cela tous cas nous à improviser
monsieur jospin était déconcertée que
président de la république et donc vous
attend dès maintenant que jacques chirac
disent que la politique de la france n'a
pas changé qui rappelle d'abord qui est
responsable de la politique de la france
est certainement pas le premier ministre
tout seul là qui au gré de ses de ses
villégiatures prend 10 6 y at il eu tout
seul comme ça et puis d'autre part qu'il
rappelle ce qu'est la position que je
crois qu'ils libre est de la france ont
moyennement en direct de jérusalem
rejoignant alan salvan comment décoder
la position de lille
je suis pas au fond le premier ministre
est il ce soir dépassé par les
répercussions que ont provoqué ces
déclarations jospin est arrivé en israël
avec la claire intention de sortir du
carcan de la politique traditionnelle de
la france au moyen-orient une politique
définie en 1967 par le général de gaulle
et dont le quai d'orsay s'est fait
depuis lors le gardien scrupuleux pour
lionel jospin cette politique est un peu
déséquilibré trop pro-arabe et
finalement néfaste aux intérêts de la
france
alors peut être porté par une série de
rencontre très amicale avec des
responsables israéliens s'est il laissé
aller à une phrase qui ne pouvait pas
passer du côté arabe
si l'on qualifie des libanais fusse-t-il
extrémistes de terroristes parce qu'il
lutte contre l'armée israéliennes sur
leur territoire ont légitimement quelque
sorte l'occupation israélienne du sud
liban et on touche alors à un dogme
essentiel de la politique française
d'autant plus essentielle qui touche un
pays cher à la france le liban est un
pays cher au président de la république
alors vraisemblablement oui lionel
jospin s'est laissé emporter n'at-il pas
juger exactement de la portée de ces
propos alors on l'a entendu il a essayé
de rectifier le tir on verra si cette
rectification suffit mais d'ores et déjà
on peut dire que les dégâts sont
importants tant ici au moyen-orient
qu'en france en terme de politique
intérieure merci à une salle rend la
visite de jean paul ii en egypte
aujourd'hui au caire cérémonie
oecuménique dans ce pays où l'immense
majorité de la population est musulmane
reste que le saint-père souhaité rendre
hommage à l'héritage chrétien de
l'egypte où demeure une communauté copte
jean paul ii appelle chrétiens et
musulmans à vivre en harmonie isabelle
cesse
c'est sous les acclamations des
chrétiens non catholiques d'égypte que
jean paul ii s'est présenté à la
cathédrale notre dame du caire à
l'occasion de cette rencontre
oecuménique
il y avait deux papes au côté du chef de
l'église catholique
visiblement épuisé le pape copte
orthodoxe le patriarche d'alexandrie
shenouda iii qui représentent la
majorité des 6 million de chrétiens en
egypte ils ne sont en effet que trois
cent mille catholiques dans la
cathédrale s'était regroupé les chefs et
les fidèles d'une multitude d'églises
chrétiennes enracinée depuis des siècles
sur cette terre d'islam mais /
différents schisme à tous jean paul ii a
lancé un appel à l'unité ouvrant le
dialogue sur la primauté de rome
principal obstacle à la réunification
des chrétiens au deuxième jour de cette
première visite d'un pape au caire les
coptes d'égypte espère aussi que ce
geste marquera le début d'un apaisement
dans un pays secoué par les tensions
entre chrétiens et musulmans
avec le temps fort de cette visite
demain le pèlerinage au mont sinaï
ce sera à nouveau l'occasion de
dialoguer entre chrétiens cette fois ci
avec les moines grec orthodoxe du
monastère sainte-catherine réticents la
venue du pape sur ces lieux bibliques
jean paul ii devrait également lancer un
appel à la paix entre juifs et musulmans
jean paul ii qui se rendra demain matin
au mont sainte catherine où se trouve le
bus en ardent là même où selon la bible
dieu est apparu à moïse la veille de ce
pèlerinage charles enderlin nous propose
cette évocation de ce lieu saint le
monastère sainte catherine en plein
désert du sinaï à 1500 mètres d'altitude
voici un des plus anciens monastères
chrétiens du monde
ils datent du 4e siècle selon la bible
c'est sur une de ces montagnes que le
monothéisme a été dotée d'une éthique
les dix commandements dictée par dieu à
moïse
jean paul 2 priera à l'extérieur des
murailles dans le jardin du monastère
en effet ce lieu n'appartient pas
l'église catholique romaine mais à
l'église grecque orthodoxe et les moines
tiennent à marquer leur différence n'est
pas un simple pèlerin il personnifie
l'église catholique romaine et le
monastère de sainte catherine a toujours
été orthodoxe là il ya une certaine
tension pour nous il est donc à la fois
un pèlerin bienvenus et nous devons
garder à l'esprit cette différence il
est le chef de l'église romaine le pape
sera invité à titre privé à l'intérieur
du monastère qu'il visitera il se
recueillera devant le fameux puits de
moïse découvrira ici cette plante
exceptionnelle qui serait sans la
tradition le fameux buisson ardent de
moïse
il entrera dans l'église de la
transfiguration qui contient un fabuleux
trésor d'icônes certaines datant du 7e
siècle
les moines expliqueront à jean paul 2
qu'ils ont d'excellentes relations avec
leurs voisins musulmans le prophète
mohammed lui même a demandé à ses
fidèles de respecter le monastère où se
trouve d'ailleurs une mosquée avant de
regagner le caire en hélicoptère jean
paul ii dira peut-être une prière dans
l'ossuaire de sainte catherine où se
trouve depuis l'an 580 les reliques de
saints stéphane au kosovo quelques 3000
serbe de mitrovica se sont rassemblés
dans le centre de la ville pour dire
qu'il ne quitterait pas cette région
rejetant passage des accusations qui se
multiplient ces derniers jours selon
lesquelles ils seraient manipulés ou aux
ordres de belgrade
dans la foule beaucoup d'enfants portant
des banderoles une manifestation sans
incident quatre et par un important
dispositif de sécurité aux états unis de
george bush junior en campagne
électorale à continuer la même politique
qu'il pratique depuis des années le
gouverneur le gouverneur du texas a
refusé de gracier celle que l'on
surnomme la veuve noire
betty ljubica a été exécuté la nuit
dernière dans une certaine indifférence
etienne leenhardt
ils n'étaient que quelques dizaines hier
soir devant la prison de huntsville au
texas à s'être mobilisés pour la cause
de betty lubitsch la cause en
l'occurrence était plutôt désespérée
comme prévu après 15 années passées dans
le couloir de la mort cette grand mère
de 62 ans a été exécuté son visage était
sans expression à 18h08 la drogue a été
injecté dans ses veines elle a été
déclarée morte à 18h18 par le médecin en
charge des exécutions jusqu'au bout
met-il hobbit sera demandé la clémence
et avocats n'ont cessé ces dernières
années d'un système sur son passé de
femme battue pour tenter de faire
comprendre la raison de ces crimes
condamné à mort pour le meurtre de son
cinquième marie soupçonné d'avoir aussi
tuer son époux précédent elle aura
jusqu'au dernier instant était soutenu
par une partie de sa famille tandis que
sans aucune retenue les fils de ces deux
derniers marie applaudissent et à
l'exécution de leur belle-mère ce soit
le tas du texas a fait ce qui était
juste en exécutant betty l'oubli
je demande à dieu de soutenir sa famille
mais maintenant elle sait ce que nous
avons ressenti le texas et parmi les 38
états américains qui appliquent encore
la peine de mort aujourd'hui celui où
l'on exécute le plus avec l'assentiment
d'une majorité de la population et donc
de la classe politique locale en
l'occurrence dur je bouge junior le
gouverneur de l'état s'est retranché
derrière la loi pour justifier son refus
de gracier vite ils oublient la mort de
betty lubitsch ne fait ce matin dans la
prestation à l'américaine que quelques
lignes d'autres exécutions sont prévues
la semaine prochaine au texas dont
celles d'un jeune homme de 31 ans odile
barsky depuis dix ans clame son
innocence en marge de l'élection
présidentielle au sénégal cette
mésaventure qui a tourné tragiquement
des touristes français ont été agressés
en casamance les deux accompagnateurs
sont morts et une personne est blessée
les voyageurs rejette la responsabilité
sur le tour opérateur et le gouvernement
français
frédéric dupuy karim comme asie
c'était le troisième jour de vacances le
jour de l'excursion en bus à ziguinchor
capitale de la casamance
très vite la vingtaine de touristes
déchante un barrage des rebelles armés
donne l'ordre de s'arrêter
ils sont montés dans le car ils ont tapé
avec les north mitraillette sur les
cross sur les vitres les enfants dans
nos murs les frais dans le car ils ont
tiré une rafale de mitraillette et nous
ont demandé l'argent alors on a donné
tout notre engin fait ce qu'on avait et
puis après ils nous ont demandés un
corpus et le guide nous a dit donner
tout ce que vous pouvez et il vaut mieux
donner sera et garder la vie et ils ont
fait descendre le vide aux chauffeurs
illisible coup franc de man 2 devant les
gosses au nord avec une balle dans la
bouche de vannes où l'armée sénégalaise
viendra à leur secours
deux heures plus tard pourquoi autant de
temps et surtout pourquoi fram le tour
opérateur at il laissé partir cette
excursion dans une zone d'affrontements
armés théâtre de nombreux crimes sur la
casamance nous avions à la fois aucune
interdiction des autorités françaises et
surtout la garantie des autorités
sénégalaises d'une surveillance et une
protection des zones touristiques de ce
pays
aucune interdiction formelle mais le
quai d'orsay se défend sur son site
internet le ministère avait prévenu du
danger
nous avions des conseillers déconseillé
de voyager par la route dans l'ensemble
la casamance et nous avions signalé que
toutefois les voyagistes maintenez le
passage par la route entre ziguinchor
caf king là où est arrivé l'accident
depuis leur retour lodges elle reste en
contact étroit avec les autres touristes
ensemble ils ont porté plainte contre le
tour opérateur et contre le gouvernement
français pour non-assistance à personne
en danger
les colonies de vacances seront telles
contraintes de payer plein pot le
personnel qui encadrent les enfants une
disposition particulière toléré jusqu'à
présent est remise en question par un
inspecteur du travail virginie fichiers
terry simoné dans ce centre de vacances
de la fédération des oeuvres laïques
cinq animateurs encadrent en permanence
une trentaine d'enfants
pourquoi on n'a pas une poignée comme
une moto
la majorité soudée collaborateur
occasionnel au titre d'une disposition
particulière à la profession ils sont
rémunérés sur une base forfaitaire de
deux heures de travail effectif par jour
bien que les horaires et les salaires
soient généralement plus élevés ce
subterfuge a été négocié il ya dix ans
pour permettre aux organisateurs de
séjours de minimiser le poids des
charges patronales
l'inspection du travail juge aujourd'hui
cette dérogation illégale et sur le
terrain une révision à la hausse 5
il est certain qu'il y aura moins
d'animateurs puisqu'on pourra pas se
permettre donc de dépenser de dépenser
plus puisque nous aurons ces charges à
payer
c'est c'est de l'argent qui rentre qui
ne rentrera plus et qui ne pourra plus
être s destination des activités des
enfants dans les formules proposées par
la fédération des oeuvres laïques les
salaires de l'encadrement représente
actuellement un quart du prix de journée
100 allègements de charge les tarifs des
séjours pourrait augmenter de 50%
face à cette explosion il est tout à
fait certain que les familles ne
pourront plus envoyer du moins peu
familles pourront envoyer leurs enfants
en centres de vacances
la fédération craint de perdre sa
vocation sociale
la solution elle viendra peut-être d'un
nouveau statut pour ces personnels
occasionnels statut actuellement à
l'étude
serait pas sous un statut de salarié il
serait bien sûr un statut de stagiaire
et ça permettrait d'échapper entre
guillemets à la réglementation
directement applicables en termes de
smic ou de charges sociales
ces futurs javaux ce gène animateurs
volontaires stagiaires pourrait bien
voir le jour juste avant les grandes
vacances
le coup d'envoi des collections du
prêt-à-porter de l'hiver 2000 l'occasion
de mieux connaître celui qui a pris la
succession de kenzo il s'appelle gilles
rozier il travaille à la fois sur sa
propre marque et sur l'héritage du
créateur japonais et que le corps du
langlois bernac honneur depuis 30 ans le
plus parisien des créateurs japonais
régner sur la place des victoires à
l'automne il est parti vers d'autres
passions d'autres voyages gilles rozier
qui travaillait avec lui pendant quatre
saisons est désormais seul à bord pour
la mode féminine mais aussi pour les
collections jungle jean et les
accessoires
c'est un défi un épanouissement
mais aussi un hommage aux références
japonaise des repères pour identifier le
style kenzo au premier coup d'oeil
il ya beaucoup de vêtements dans la
collection qui ont cet effet justement
basculé avec le cas des kimonos dû
porter masculin j'aimais bien ce côté
très décroché au niveau de l'épaule et
qui qui fait donc un effet de bénéficier
rattrapé par des ceintures et basse au
niveau des hanches sont alignés plaqué
au niveau des hanches ans en général
j'aime bien mettre les têtes sur un
élément du col
une adolescence nomades à travers
l'afrique il a gardé le goût du
métissage les couleurs du voyage et de
la fête comme kenzo
jeudi il présentera 115 modèle sur 60
mannequin un grand spectacle et ils
ambitionnent
et intérieurement je bouillonne amusé
sévérité zen comme l'était lemaitre 10
minutes de marche et le voilà chez lui
dans le marais où il redevient
totalement lui-même dans cet hôtel xviie
siècle se trouvent les ateliers le
studio gilles rozier
lundi matin il présentera sous son nom
une collection plus modestes 60 modèles
sur votre mannequin mais surtout un
style plus dépouillé ces deux histoires
différentes
l'essentiel est plus toujours raconter
une histoire à partir du moment où je
raconte une histoire
je courais en meute relief il cite
volontiers sartre l'homme et la somme de
ces that jugement cette semaine sur les
deux versions de sa création
vous avez peut-être en mémoire les
déclarations de christophe bass ans
qualifié de monsieur propre sur le tour
de france l'an passé qui n'avait pas
hésité à dénoncer les pratiques de
dopage dans le peloton
les conséquences ont tardé mais
aujourd'hui elle le rattrape puisque le
champion cycliste se voit écarté du
système de primes au sein de sa propre
équipe
nathanaël de rincquesen sept mois après
le tour de france christophe bassons
continue de payer ses prises de position
contre le dopage
cette fois le coup vient de son ancienne
équipe la française des jeux
dans une lettre signée par ces huit
coéquipiers la saison passée christophe
bassons est informé qu'il ne touchera
rien des primes remporté sur le tour 99
pour le coureur cela constitue un manque
à gagner de 25 mille francs la raison
qu'ils ont données propres comme quoi il
voulait pas protégé avec moi c'est que
simplement ils ont dit que que j'ai été
nuisible à leur image sur le tour 99
christophe bassons fait parler lui et
pour ses déclarations dans le peloton
comme au sein de son équipe
basson et critique et isolé il abandonne
à la 12e étape aujourd'hui le porte
parole des coureurs de la française des
jeux explique la décision de son équipe
basson n'a pas fait son boulot ils ont
considéré que ce mais s'il n'avait pas
pris part au travail collectif de
l'équipe qu'il avait fait preuve
d'individualisme et ne par là même ils
n'entendaient pas le rémunéré pour un
travail qu'il n'avait pas effectué en
aucun cas c'est décision n'étant rapport
avec les prises de position de ce
dernier sur le sujet du dopage
devant la sanction financière qui le
frappe christophe bassons et une autre
explication pour lui c'est un règlement
de comptes
on réfléchit vérité me le fera à 8
coureurs pour eux ça va pas faire grand
chose donc je crois que c'est pas
vraiment pour l'argent qu'ils ont fait
ce que tout simplement ça a été je pense
pour m'embêter et que qu'apparemment je
laisser déranger l'année de l'année
dernière et donc ils ont voulu me le
faire payer cette saison christophe
bassons a changé l'équipe
dans quelques jours il retrouvera le
peloton et tous ses anciens coéquipiers
de la française des jeux
les discussions risquent d'être animés
l'écrivain américain paul auster a écrit
dans les années 70 au début de sa
carrière et une pièce de théâtre laurel
et hardy vont paradis hommage aux deux
célèbres comiques et théâtre de
l'absurde à la fois michel celui ci fuit
déjà cela
l'entrée du couple laurel et hardy dans
le cinéma comique en a bouleversé les
critères et les acides foliques
destruction recherche de l'absurde
les deux complices ont été célébrées
dans le monde entier et ils ont
influencé le regard de nombre de
créateurs dont celui de l'écrivain
américain paul auster sa première pièce
de théâtre leur rend hommage
laurel et hardy sur injonction d'ordre
supérieur dont on ne sait qui exactement
les donnes doivent construire un mur et
la logique des bâtisseurs s'emballe les
pierres seront mises en place dans
l'ordre suivant rangée supérieure
lapierre 13 sera placée au dessus de la
pierre s'est elle même au dessus de la
pierre 5 elle même à côté de la 1/2 la
case de trait sur l'a11 en plein appel à
12 à côté des huit sur l'a6 à côté de la
quatre l'activité humaine fait vu ici
comme une suite d'actions van damme sert
à rien fait comment parler légèrement de
choses graves
les choses rares c'est le sens de la vie
la villa mais oui je vais où allons nous
où allons-nous pourquoi fait ça parce
que tout ça a un sens et de s'intéresser
dans le genre de questions que personne
n'ose poser les questions du petit matin
très tôt voyez laurel et hardy balance
de certitudes on incertitudes
je ne peux pas je crois que personne ne
pourra le faire mais nous sommes se sait
faire tout ce qui est écrit
personne ne peut faire ça c'est
impossible que l'on vous faire on ne
peut pas renoncer comme ça peut-être
qu'on est sensé renoncer après tout on a
fait de notre mieux pas vrai mais
peut-être comme un premier n'est pas
assez bien
il n'y a rien de mieux que le mieux le
mur que les deux complices construisent
et détruisent c'est pour paul auster la
métaphore de la condition humaine
sa fin de ce journal je rappelle les
principaux titres
la veuve de l'ancien préfet de corse
publie une lettre ouverte demandant au
gouvernement de se positionner
clairement sur la question de l'amnistié
l'indignation de madame erignac qui sort
de son silence
les déclarations de lionel jospin sur le
hezbollah libanais déclenché une petite
tempête diplomatique et politique le
premier ministre parle d'une autre voie
que celle du chef de l'état aujourd'hui
il tente de dédramatiser
dans un instant la météo nathalie
rihouet pu le croire août valérie
maurice 20h55 votre politique de
vendredi boulevard du palais minuit le
dernier journal lance sow nasa demain 7h
dans thé ou café
catherine ceylac reçoit laure adler
directrice de radio france genre et
quant à moi le plaisir de vous
retrouvez demain dès 13h je vous
remercie de votre attention excellente
fin de soirée sur france 2
à